Welcome back to
Academy Dialogues.
This is our final episode this
season and the conversation
today is Broadening the
Aperture of Excellence.
This conversation is moderated
by filmmaker, changemaker,
and Academy Governor,
Ava DuVernay.
Joining Ava, two inspiring
and highly regarded
filmmakers, Julie
Dash and Euzhan Palcy.
On to you, Ava.
Thank you, Shawn.
Thank you to the Academy for
giving us the time, space,
the platform to talk,
and for some of you
learn more about two truly
extraordinary filmmakers.
These are my cinematic
heroes, and I'm so honored--
I feel emotional, even been
saying it and being in the room
with you both, and
it's a virtual room.
This is crazy, but
I'll take it, because I
love you both so much.
So many people
always talk about,
Ava, you're the first
this, first that,
and I never lose an opportunity
to talk about the women
who not only came before,
but who I had the opportunity
to work beside.
Because these women
are dynamic directors
who were working long before
I was, and who still are.
And so I'm so pleased to
have Miss Dash, Miss Palcy,
the queens, here with us today.
And our real goal
here is for people
who don't know about the
dynamic, lush, delicious,
acclaimed work of the two
of you to get to know it.
And so often when I hear
you all interviewed,
it's talking from
a sense of lack,
of absence, all the
things that happened,
all the hardships
within the industry.
And what I want to do is
let this be a real filmmaker
conversation about craft, about
the way that you see your work
as artists and about your
mastery of the craft,
because you both are masters.
So we shall begin
with two Black girls
born in the '50's,
one in Martinique
and one in New York City.
Here they are, and I want to
know, first films you saw?
How did you first start
to fall in love with film?
I know Euzhan, you would go
to the matinees in Martinique.
Can you talk a little
bit about how you
started to come to love movies?
That's right.
We used to go to the--
priest had a room that
he turned into a theater,
and we would go to see
movies after the big service
after 11:00 AM, and
our parents would
go in the evening to see a
different kind of movies.
So that's where I was
able to discoverer
of for example like a
Black Orpheus from Camus.
And I saw, for the first time,
Black people on screen kissing,
and loving, and children.
And I was so happy, because
I'd been so starving
and frustrated with not
seeing our people on screen.
And I saw others of color.
Of course, but you're
in the priest's room.
So you've gone to
mass, then you went
into the priest's back room
and watched matinee movies.
And could you have ever
imagined your path then?
Can you give us
the summary of how
you got from that girl
in the priest's room
watching Black Orpheus to
the set of Sugar Cane Alley.
What came in between?
Well, what happened was that
I decided to make films,
I was 10 years old.
Because we were going to
the movies all the time,
and most of those films would
come from Europe or America.
As I said earlier, I was
always forcefully not seeing
any Black faces, people like me.
So after I would see a movie,
I would question my parents.
I would say, but how come
we are not on the screen,
we are absent?
My mother would
say, I don't know.
But I would question
her so much, so much,
they would call me
Mademoiselle Why--
Miss Why.
[CHUCKLING]
And my grandmother would
say to me, you know what?
I'll give you 20 minutes if you
want to-- you complain about
things--
but I'll give you 10
minutes to tell me
how you're going to change
this, what do you want
to do to it makes a difference?
And she was talking
like that to me.
And one day my mother
wanted me to get out
of her space in the
kitchen, because I
kept questioning, questioning.
And she gave me a book, the
book is Sugar Cane Alley.
In French is La Rue
Cases-Nègres, Sugar Cane Alley.
Sit down, read that book, and
please, read every single page.
Don't flip the pages, because
I want to do the story,
I know it by heart myself.
But she didn't know
that simple gesture
to get her peace, that
gesture which in her own life,
because it was just like
a hurricane in my body.
And I saw my people for
the first time in a book--
Black folks, children, old
people, Africa, Africans.
And I said, oh, I want to
make a movie with that,
and that stuck with me
for years and years.
And that's how-- it was
a struggle after that
to get the money
to make the movie,
but that's another thing.
That's another story.
It's always a struggle
to make a movie,
but I love the fact that you
describe it as a hurricane that
happened within you.
And anybody who has seen Miss
Palcy's classic, seminal Sugar
Cane Alley then you've missed
out, but you can fix it.
Go find it, and watch her work.
Miss Dash, Queen Dash--
New York City, rough
and tumble, that's
what I think of New York City.
Queensbridge Projects,
that's right.
How did you first
start to see films?
And at what age?
Younger or older?
I was very young.
I just remember there
was the Beacon Theater
was the only theater
in Queensbridge
Projects across the
street from where
I grew up on Vernon Boulevard.
I used to go to the movies
and fall asleep all the time.
Movies were
different then, there
were two movies
plus ten cartoons.
And they would have to wake me
up when it was time to leave.
I had really no plans
of being a filmmaker,
I didn't even know
how films were made.
I thought the actors were
making up the lines as they were
going along, I didn't know.
But Black Orpheus-- I remember
I saw it for the first time
on television.
My mother woke my sister
and myself up from sleep
and said, hurry up,
come see the television,
Black people are on television,
and it was Black Orpheus.
Wow.
And it was late at
night, and it was dubbed.
And I realized that I'd never
seen a dubbed film before,
so it was like, hmm, a little,
something is a little strange.
But everyone was like really
hot and moving around,
and there were Black people,
and they were beautiful,
and they were dancing.
And it was like, oh, that's
just like the people I know.
But it's kind of strange, it's
something with the voices.
[CHUCKLING]
It was hyper reality.
But it was Black Orpheus,
and that stuck with me.
And to this day, it remains
one of my favorite films.
But let's leap frog this, in
1968, I was in high school,
and I stumbled into a
filmmaking workshop in Harlem
called the Studio
Museum of Harlem.
They had a
cinematography workshop.
We were there for something
like two weeks, my best friend,
Wembe, and I. We were
there for about two weeks
before we realized it wasn't
a still photography class,
it was cinematography.
So by that time we were hooked.
We were watching Jules and Jim,
and all these foreign films,
Potemkin, Eistenstein's
Potemkin, and Tokyo Story.
And I was just
hooked at that point.
And pretty much like Euzhan
was saying, at that point,
I started wondering, why are
the films so much better?
The foreign films, why can't
we see ourselves on the screen?
Why can't we see
renditions of Sula,
or The Bluest Eye, Toni
Morrison's work, Alice Walker's
work, Gayl--
the woman who wrote Corregidora,
I forget her last name.
But that was pretty
much, by the time
I got to college, that's why I
wanted to become a filmmaker,
so I could start
telling those stories
and learning how to
tell those stories.
So then you and your feature
narrative directorial debut
is Daughters of the Dust.
The long form.
But I had made
quite a few films.
You had made quite a few, that's
why I asked it as a question,
because it's the featured,
narrative directorial debut was
Daughters of the Dust.
It just happened to
be a lifelong classic,
this is the first
one, it's fine.
And so the two of
you are making films,
and debuting your
cinematic voices
to the world around the same
time, within a four or five
year window of one another.
And so I wanted to just talk
a little bit about that time,
the late '80's, early '90's.
And I look at old pictures
of the two of you,
and I have pored over pictures
of the two of you on your sets
and all of your
publicity photos,
and I've read every interview.
But I just want you
to take us back,
because there were
there was so few of you,
and yet there were
a lot more than it
had been all in that time.
I think you can count
about a dozen filmmakers
around that time that
were making work of note.
And yet, only a
handful of women.
So how that felt being
at that renaissance,
that Black renaissance
of film '80's,
early '90's, and what the
point of view of women
with the next circle was?
Did you all know each other?
Were you all talking
to each other?
Were you supporting each other?
What-- were the Americans
in touch with filmmakers who
were outside of the country?
How was it?
Well, I met Euzhan at--
PBS had a retreat in Utah.
Do you remember that,
the Sundance Retreat?
Yes.
That was the first time
I met her in person,
but I knew her
films before then.
Of course, Rue Cases Négres
was one of my favorites,
because it's a foreign film.
So I knew her.
And I started traveling to
various international film
festivals at a very young
age with my short films.
We went to London,
France, Munich, Venice,
all of these places.
And so we were interacting with
African filmmakers in France.
Med Hondo, Idrissa,
[INAUDIBLE],, all of these people
long before I made
Daughters of the Dust.
OK.
Wow, and Euzhan, how
do you remember it?
You know what, I saw
Daughters of the Dust
when I came to America.
Because American
film would not go
to Europe for the simple
reason that, even the studios
today, they are telling us that
when you win a project, well,
you know, we won't be
able to market this,
foreign won't like
it, they won't buy it.
And it's complicated, because
the leads are Black or females
don't even talk about that.
So for that reason, there
were very few Americans--
American films with Black
folks, Black heroes.
That piece is a beautiful
piece, a masterpiece.
I've already told you
about how beautiful
that movie was, the people, the
directing, and the photography,
it was fantastic.
I was talking about it with
my friend, Jean-Pierre,
because he doesn't
know the film,
and I will make sure
that you see that movie.
And then when we met, I was
just like, [GASP],, of course.
Because I was so
lonely, and that's
hard when you are like that.
When you are the only one, you
have nobody like you around,
and when we met, it was great.
Wow, that's so interesting
that concept of loneliness.
And I think I just
want to talk about that
in a context of the women
who influenced you and came
before you.
And I know from talking to you
and having the honor of you
both spending time
with me personally,
that you both have quite the
connection to Kathleen Collins.
And so I wanted to take
a little bit of time
in this space to talk about
our beautiful sister, Kathleen
Collins.
And for people that do not
know, regrettably, who she was
and what she left
behind, can you
talk a little bit about
how you knew her and bit
about her work?
Euzhan, can you start us off?
Yeah, I was in Boston,
and she invited me there
with my film, Sugar Cane Alley.
And there was a screening,
a documentary that they
did about her, but she was
dead, she died a few years
before that screening.
I didn't know
anything about her,
and there it is, I'm
sitting there, watching
that woman, that
passionate woman,
and talking about acting.
She had [INAUDIBLE],, and
also, she was so angry,
because she wanted to do
more, and Hollywood would not
give her what she would need
just to make her feature films.
And she was talking about
all kinds of things.
When I was watching her
and listening to her,
I recognized myself in her--
my passion, the
fight I had to put on
to do Sugar Cane Alley
and all of these things.
And I started to cry
when I understood
that she died from
cancer, and young, she
was 40 or something like that.
Yeah.
Oh my God, I started to cry,
and I'm saying that, I have oof.
And at the end of the
screening at that festival,
I decided to look for
her husband, Alfred,
and he told me that
he was in New York,
and they gave me the
address, and I called him.
And I said, I need to talk
to you, I need to meet you.
And instead of going back to
Paris, I changed my boarding,
and I went to New York.
And I sat with him,
we had breakfast.
And I said, you don't know me,
but I just discovered a movie
about your wife.
And I just--
[SPEAKING FRENCH],,
as we say in French.
And I'm so moved,
and I would like
to do something that she wanted
to do, she has other projects.
And he told me
about two projects.
One with about three old
stars, Black stars, you know.
They took a cruise
in the Caribbean
and they discovered a new
world, they discovered life,
they had a good time.
And then he said,
well, she had also
a project about to the
first Negro female pilots
called Bessie Coleman.
And I said, oh, and he
said, yes, and guess what?
She went to France, she had to
expatriate herself to France
for a year in order
to get her license,
because it was 1918, 1919.
And I said, you're kidding me?
In France?
Yes, and I said, my God.
And I said, OK, I know why.
I saw that as a call,
and I said, look,
I made a promise to you today.
I'm making the promise
to direct that movie,
I want to make that
movie for Kathleen.
And I said, I have to do that.
And then I went to
Chicago and I met
Bessie's relative, one
of them, her niece,
and I found the grave.
I went there, and I knelt
in front of that grave,
and I made the same
promise to Bessie.
And I said look, I made
a promise to Kathleen,
now I'm here, sister.
Pray for me wherever
you are, because I'm
going to hell after Sugar
Cane Alley, [INAUDIBLE]
didn't want my movie.
We will go through
hell for your story,
so I need all the vibrations
that you can send me
so we can make that movie.
And you're going
to make that movie,
and you're still
working on that movie,
and I'm helping you
make that movie.
We're making this
movie somehow, but this
is Euzhan Palcy's Bessie
Coleman, that is a wish project
Kathleen Collins.
And this is part of her legacy.
Julie, Kathleen Collins for you.
I'm glad that we're
taking some time
to speak about her
influence on you both.
Absolutely, Kathleen Collins.
Well, I think I met
her about 1971 or 1972.
I was an undergraduate school at
City College in New York City.
And I was assigned a
summer work study job
with Chamba Productions.
Chamba, of course, was
headed by St. Clair
Bourne, documentary filmmaker.
And there were five
Chamba brothers--
Charles Hobson, and
Garrett, all of them.
And they had just come back from
shooting a film in the South
called, Let the Church Say Amen.
And a young woman show up
who was going to edit it.
And that young woman
was Kathleen Collins.
And she was fresh out of
the Sorbonne in Paris,
speaking French--
a Black woman speaking French--
and she was a vegetarian.
So like I always say, like
coming out of the projects,
I'm like, a vegetarian?
OK, what is that, exactly?
So anyway, that summer,
it was like the summer
of Kathleen Collins.
She was so friendly and
so competent in her craft.
She'd be working in the editing
bay, and I'd kind of peek
in every now and
then, and then she
said would say, no, come
in, she would say, come in.
And I would sit with her,
and she would just edit.
She had a baby, a newborn
baby. sometimes I'd
sit with her holding the baby.
It was incredible, but
I just never forgot her.
And then I after that,
I graduated and went out
to Los Angeles.
But she started making films
of her own, feature films--
The Cruz Brothers and Mrs.
Malloy, Losing Ground,
all of these films.
And we stayed in touch, we saw
each other at film festivals
and things like that.
And then suddenly
she passed away,
and I went to her
memorial service.
All of us were there,
and everyone was a wreck.
It was shocking, it
was sad, it was tragic,
because everything
was just cut short,
just taken away from her.
And by that time, she
was eating macrobiotics.
So I was angry, because it
was like, this is not fair,
she ate well.
She was so creative, she was
so open, loving, and talented.
And I just had never met
anyone like her before,
so she like the
goddess of film for me.
Yes.
It's so important, thank
you for sharing that.
I got emotional as you
were talking about it
I think it's so important
to talk about her,
because the Academy, the very
platform that has given us
this space to talk,
has long excluded
the voices of women and people
of color in its conversation
about history.
I'm so encouraged by
the new museum that's
being put up by the Academy and
all the great work being done
by all of the folks there,
a great coalition of people
to really make
sure that we really
capture so much of what the
organization had systemically
ignored.
And most of us weren't
there at the time
that those early decisions
were made, but we're here now.
And so I'm so happy that
she, and both of your work,
is included in the
museum, and it's
going to be talked
about as we go forward.
Speaking of your starts and how
you came up in that early work,
I just want to move in to talk
a little bit about what many
would consider the time
when you came on the scene
and you were able to present
your work to audience.
And so I'm hoping
that you all can
talk to me about the
connection and the moments
when your work has
connected to audience.
Not necessarily with
the most famous films,
but the experiences having
maybe not the most robust
distribution, not
the best marketing,
but the ways in which,
despite all of that--
despite lack of consistent
industry recognition--
you've been able to cultivate
an audience for your work.
How have you achieved that
over these past decades?
Persistence of vision.
[CHUCKLING]
And not allowing anyone to tell
you what you can and can't do.
What people don't understand
for the most part, for me,
I never had dreams of
working in Hollywood.
I had dreams of
being a storyteller,
I had dreams of making
films, and experimenting
with ways of telling a
story, and that I have done.
I made a little Super
8 film years ago back
in the '70's that played at
Film Ex, Los Angeles Film
Exposition.
And today it's been blown
up to 35 millimeter.
That cracked me up.
And it's in distribution.
It's a little short.
I did another little short
called Four Women which
won best film at the Miami
International Film Festival
maybe in 1976, 1979,
or something like that.
But it's on the
books as having won,
and that's in distribution.
So I enjoy what I do, and yes,
I wish I had the opportunity
to have more feature
length films,
but I have about five other
movies made for television.
But we could get into
that later, I want
to hear what Euzhan has to say.
About cultivating
audience over these years,
Euzhan, when the industry might
not have helped with that,
might not have encouraged that.
And yet you persisted.
Yeah, it was hell,
let's call a cat a cat.
But persistence is a key thing.
You have to keep pushing
and pushing the boundaries.
And when they get you out
the room through the door,
you come back in the windows.
That's what I have
been doing for years.
And you do watch.
If you come to
feature because you
don't want your
movies too Black, too
whatever, [INAUDIBLE] cable.
Well, you do documentaries--
I love good documentaries,
because they're
about people, people's lives,
real things, real lives.
Or you do series, you
work with a network,
like I did for Ruby
Bridges for, example.
I did all of the aftermath of
the Attica Uprising called,
The Killing Yard.
And I also did a French
series about the populating
of the country near Mauritius
island, [SPEAKING FRENCH]..
At the time it was
a period piece,
seventeenth century
called Bourbon Island.
I did a two part series.
And you both moved into
television which would
allow you to tell more stories.
Julie has a
beautiful filmography
with telefilms, your wonderful
work on Rosa Parks with Angela
Bassett.
So much of the work that
you've both done in television.
The reason why I asked the
question about consistency
and how you continue on to the
industry providing audience
for you, is because
I've learned so much
from that about the idea of.
Mastery, I use
that word, Julie--
when I hear the word mastery, I
think of Kerry James Marshall.
Kerry James Marshall, just
one of the finest artists
on the planet whose
work, he can just
decide he wants to throw
some paint on a canvas
and it's going to sell
for a cool $20 mil.
And it was the
production designer
on Daughters of the Dust.
But the idea of
mastery, the idea
of who gets to choose
who is a master.
We are sitting here on a
platform from the Academy,
and you all have had
great achievement.
But the idea of
mastery being connected
to audience and your
work, not the achievement,
is something that I've
learned from both of you,
because you are masters, you
are auteurs of great note.
And yet the industry has
never fully acknowledged that,
and welcomed you, and
did not help you along,
and yet you achieved it.
So I want to ask you about
that idea of looking back, you
see contemporaries
of yours who are
your white male counterparts
who were immediately considered
masters of their field,
and the industry rose up
to support them.
How do you reconcile
that day to day
and be able to stay
healthy in your own work?
Well, it's interesting, because
I was in AFI the same time
as Amy Heckerling, Mimi Leder,
Marshall Herskovitz, Ed Zwick,
all these people who have a
long list of feature films
that they were able to make.
And I look at that
sometimes, and I say,
I wonder where I would have
been or what I could have done.
But then on the other side of
that is, I would not perhaps
have been able to say, I
want Kerry James Marshall
to production design my film if
I had been working in industry.
Daughters of the Dust was
a very independent film.
I would not have been able
to say I want Arthur J for AJ
to be the DP on my
film, which he was,
and he won award for
best cinematography
at Sundance for that film.
So in many ways working
with masters of art--
being able to recognize,
and pull them in, and work
with them was a wonderful
thing that added
to whatever I was trying to do.
You know the old saying, you
always want to be in a room
with people who are
smarter than you.
Well, I've always
want to be in a room
with people who have a
mastery of the craft greater
than my own so I can learn too.
And it is just a joy to
work with people like that.
And I've done that all along.
I've also done a
lot of museum work.
Films for museums,
commercials, car commercials,
and all those things.
And on each production, no
matter how large or small,
I learn something,
and it's wonderful.
So you've been able to
harmonize that for yourself
and see the positives in
what you were able to do.
Absolutely.
I think it's
important, because when
I hear people talk about you
and Euzhan, what I hate is the,
oh, if they only,
you know, poor--
these women are
dynamic and vibrant.
Euzhan, what is your thought
about that whole idea
of mastery and who gets to
be the masters of cinema
and how you fit into that?
Well, I would like to say that
when I did Sugar Cane Alley,
I didn't have a production
company, but I had some money.
I raised some money,
and French government
helped to get me a grant.
I did a job--
the producer's job-- as well.
I wrote the screenplay,
and I directed the film,
and also, I acted
as a producer, but I
didn't get any credit for that,
because I didn't even care,
because I just wanted
to make that movie.
And to picture the
people that helped me,
because that was my first film.
And I went to one of the
best film school in Paris,
but still.
And I was the first Black woman
coming out of that school,
Louis Lumiére acting school.
François Truffaut
is one, the French,
that very famous
French director.
And he's the one who
advised me about the crew.
He suggested some masters
in different categories.
And that's how I was able to
build my first creative crew,
bring people together,
to do my first thing.
After that, I didn't
want to go to Hollywood
to work with Hollywood,
because Hollywood attracted me.
I never thought that.
I would fit in, because
it's a totally different way
of working.
If you compare Hollywood and
Europe, it's totally different.
And in fact, [INAUDIBLE],, it's a
long story, but after Sundance,
the five letters that Warner
Brothers sent me to ask me
to come, because he loved--
We have to go back a step,
because Robert Redford,
you were in the
first Sundance Labs,
Robert Redford
invited you up when
no one knew what Sundance was.
He's in the woods, where is he?
What is he doing?
OK, I'll go.
And he was also a part of the
connection with you to Sony,
right?
For A Dry White Season?
A Dry White Season, yes,
with Warner Brothers.
Yeah, Warner Brothers, OK.
And because what
he did, in fact,
when you got to Sundance Lab,
you need to have a project,
and I came with a book, A Dry
White Season written by André
Brink.
So he was very
attentive to my work,
and we had many conversations
sitting on the grass.
And one day he said, OK,
so now you are going back
home, what are you going to do?
I said, well, I
don't know, yeah, I
think I will go back home.
And I showed him
the five letters
that Lucy Fisher
from Warner Brothers
wrote me to ask me insistently,
come, and let's work together,
we would like to work with
you, we adore Sugar Cane Alley.
And he said, OK, you should
go, you should try it.
You should try it.
And I said, no, I
don't want my life
to be miserable, because I
don't think I will would fit in,
because I know what I want,
I know how I want to do this,
and to be able to decide for
my stories and everything.
And that's not always
how Hollywood works.
And he said, no, I think
that you should go.
You are a strong woman.
Go and just discuss
with them, and try it.
And then he called Lucy Fisher,
they put me on the plane,
and that's how I
arrived in Hollywood.
And I came with that project.
And it was not easy,
Lucy was very happy,
she offered me a lot of movies.
But I said no, no, no, no.
She even offered me--
sorry, I forget the title.
But that's OK.
[CHUCKLING]
But cut to, you end up
directing Marlon Brando
and being the first Black
director to direct an actor
to an Oscar nomination.
And you also won
the César, right?
Was it the César for A Dry White
Season or for Sugar Cane Alley?
Oh, for Sugar Cane Alley, yes,
I am the first female director
who got César, the French César,
you know the French Oscar,
I was once with
Americans for a movie.
Yes.
And so this idea
of mastery, do you
feel like a master of
cinema, let me ask you that?
A master?
A master.
Am I saying the
right word in French?
Like a master.
You know what, I always
saw myself like a shoemaker
on a mission.
[CHUCKLING]
And fighting to do--
I want to make films, I want--
I used to say that
with my camera
that I call my
miraculous weapon,
I'm trying to heal the
wounds created by history.
I'm trying to reveal things
that had been hidden,
or destroyed, or stolen.
And I'm trying to
talk about this
and to bring people together.
That's what I'm trying to do.
That's I want to do that with--
I'm doing it, and I try to
keep doing it with respect,
with love, with
passion, and a smile.
[INAUDIBLE] smile and smile.
That's right.
Well, I consider
you both masters.
And just as we start to wrap up,
I want to talk about the things
that you have ahead,
because I think
it's really
important that people
know that you are filmmakers,
and you are making work.
This is not a time
capsule, we're
not opening up the
old vaults to say,
look at what they
did, we want to say,
look at what they're doing.
So I just want to invite
you to talk a little bit--
I'll start with Euzhan
and end with Julie--
about your projects that you're
working on now and things
that you're excited about.
Well, actually another
project that I had
and that were dear to
my heart and that he
rejected for the same
reason that we talk about.
Because you would think that you
are not worthy- to open a movie
and win an audience in the
series or to be sold to foreign
what was a [INAUDIBLE] mistake.
So now I have been revisiting
all these projects,
because this is the right time.
I truly believe I was very
patient, I did other stuff,
I did a lot of
writing, and I have
a few projects on the table.
Like Bessie Coleman, of course,
Bessie Coleman, and the story
is set in the States
and in France.
And I also have comedies.
I have one that
is a multi-racial
French and American
comedy set in Hollywood,
a very great restaurant.
And I have also a true
story called Blackville.
The story takes place in 1864,
Baltimore, Paris, and Germany.
And it is a biracial
love story, and there
is everything in it-- action,
politics, it's a thriller.
It's a big piece, fantastic.
[INAUDIBLE]
Wow, three projects you
have in your back pocket.
Busy.
Miss Dash?
You're working on
99 things as well?
You're teaching at Spelman.
I'm teaching at Spelman,
I have a documentary
in progress called Travel
Notes of a Geechee Girl.
And it's about Vertamae
Smart-Grosvenor, who
was a culinary anthropologist.
She was a close friend, she
passed away two years ago,
and she would advise me
on Daughters of the Dust,
she was from the region too.
I'm also working on
a film for Lionsgate.
We're developing the
autobiography of Angela Davis.
Yay!
Dramatic feature.
We've been working
on that for a while.
But I have another project,
and it's a limited series,
and it's called Eleanor
Roosevelt's Battalion,
and it's about the 850
African-American women who
served overseas
during World War II,
and they're also known as
the 6888 Postal Battalion.
So that is a project
that's really dear to me,
and hopefully we could
get that going this year.
Yes, very busy.
And let me ask you, though all
these projects sound amazing,
let me ask you one
other question.
I just want to ask
a craft question,
because, like I said, so often
we're asked about identity,
we're asked about our histories,
our culture, our community,
all of which we love.
But as women
filmmakers, especially
as Black women filmmakers, we're
so rarely asked about craft.
So I want to do a speed round.
Euzhan, speed round.
Miss Dash, speed round.
I'm going to ask the
question, and then we're
going to go back to
back on the answer.
I'm going to try
to get in three.
Ready?
OK.
[GIGGLING]
OK, when you are at on
set and you are rolling,
do you like to be in video
village at your monitors?
Or do you like to be watching
the action with your eye?
Do you prefer
monitors or your eye?
Euzhan?
The monitors.
Monitors.
Julie?
I never had monitors before,
now I do, so monitors.
You're like, I've got monitors,
I'm not letting them go.
I couldn't afford
them before, go ahead.
OK, all right.
Rehearsal.
OK, rehearsal techniques--
what is your trick?
You have an actor on set, stuck,
can't get it, not getting it,
time is ticking, you
gotta do something.
What do you pull out?
What's that the Julie Dash
trick to get it going?
Julie?
I ask them to speak the role
of the person acting against,
so I flip it.
And it frees them up?
Yeah, it frees them
up, because then they
can understand the
other person's position,
and then they could go
back to theirs, and say oh.
Ooh, I can use that one.
[GIGGLING]
Euzhan?
Well, to answer for that
question I'll take an example.
In A Dry White Season, there
is a very tough, very emotional
scene when Stanley,
who is a Black South
Africans, a Black cab
driver, he gave it
to the white guys,
the white lead,
his colleague's
house at Christmas.
And he came, and
in fact, he came
to deliver some
kind of bad news,
and he's supposed to be crying.
He would be in tears,
he would be in tears.
He couldn't cry, Zakes
Mokae, he couldn't cry.
We tried everything,
and time was running.
And I said, OK, we
stop everything,
and I said, stay put,
stay tuned, guys.
And I walked outside
with him, and I said,
Stanley, what is going on?
Talk to me fast.
He said, I don't
know, I can't cry.
And I said, OK, you
are South African,
I know that they killed your
brother, they tortured him,
they hang him, and they said
that he committed suicide.
They did the same
thing with your dad.
Do you remember when
you got the news?
How you felt about this?
He said, yes.
And I said, I want you to go
back to room, have the scene,
and then when you
get to the floor,
then you see your
brother, you see your dad,
and you remember that
emotion, give it to me.
And that's exactly what he did.
And he was crying like crazy.
That's it.
You tapped into the
personal, the backstory.
Got it.
You make them remember.
Third and last
question about craft--
why doesn't anyone
talk about post?
It's part of my favorite part
of the process, love it so much.
We have all different
parts of post.
As a Black woman
filmmaker I'm so
rarely asked about my
process, and no one
asks anybody about post.
So we know there's so many
different parts of post.
What is your favorite
part of post?
Editorial?
Music?
Color?
VFX?
What's your favorite?
Euzhan?
Well, I love everything,
but my favorite?
I would say the
editing, but also
when we put all the
little things around.
And to create an atmosphere,
[INAUDIBLE] to things.
Because I believe that the
directing, mise-en-scène,
it goes that far.
Yes.
And after you do that, that's
a moment, one of the moments
that I love the most.
I love the directing a
lot, and I love the post.
Two things I adore.
Yes, what is your favorite
part of post, Miss Dash?
Editing, because that's
where the film is made.
Editing is a continuation
of directing.
Yes.
You start carving out scenes
to make them even better.
Even better, even better.
Anything I haven't
asked you that you
want to make sure we say?
Anything?
Well, I would like
to address, Julie,
if you feel like, a message
to the young generation,
because people consider us
as trailblazers, Julie and I.
But I feel like it
hurts me to realize
that a young generation, even
if we paved the way for many,
but that's not the problem.
But they don't know
about our work,
because nobody teaches
them about Julie's work
and about my work.
They don't even know we exist.
And I think that
there is something
that we as the Academy
needs to do about it make
them know that we existed, we
were there, we did the work,
we carry the fight,
and the fight is not
over to bring Black folks.
Because we have been fighting
for decades to bring diversity
on the screen.
That's what we have been
doing, right, Julie?
Yes, absolutely.
And I think the most
disheartening thing
is when my agent is told that
I don't have enough experience.
[GASP]
I know.
Oh my god.
How old was your agent?
[LAUGHING]
I hope your agent gives
them a mouth full.
Well, I hope so.
He's really great.
But that's what I've been told
by very episodic producers
and show runners.
You see, that's why we need
to be at the table as decision
makers in all departments--
screenplay, writing,
production, distribution,
behind the camera, in front
of the camera, everywhere.
Everybody, all the diversity--
Native American, Black,
African-American, Latino,
Asian.
Yes.
You're right.
I want to end this by--
first of all, thank
you so much for this.
If you can direct someone who
has never seen any of your work
to one scene in
any of your films--
this is a hard one.
Y'all have made a lot
of films, a lot of TV,
a lot of beautiful stories.
But if there's one scene
that you can say, watch this,
and you will understand
a bit more about me.
This scene will introduce
you to me and my work.
What would that be?
Actually, for me, it would
be a little unknown film
I did with the Urban Bush
Women called Praise House.
It's about a young
artist who doesn't speak,
her grandmother speaks for her.
And what's the scene?
The scene of her
drawing in a huge Bible,
and her grandmother's
narrating who she is,
and what she does, and doesn't
understand why she continues on
with her art.
It's really quirky.
OK, all right.
I like that.
Women are leaping
around the place
and doing backflips,
and dancing, and stuff.
Yeah, that's kind of me.
That's you, OK.
I'm going to try to find that.
And for you, Miss Palcy?
Well, I guess the scene in
Sugar Cane Alley, my first film.
When the grandmother
decided to got
to the capital 25 or
30 kilometers away
from our home, her town, just
to establish herself living
in a box that they used to
carry American cow to bring
to the country, to Martinique.
And then people will
take those boxes
and transform that into a home
for them, the poor people.
And she will do that just to
take her son to the school,
because he had a grant,
and he had to go to school.
And how, in that scene,
in the colonial era,
and how the people will
deal with her and the child.
And it's a very moving scene,
heartbreaking, but so strong,
because that old woman
said, OK, they are
doing that to discourage me.
But you are going
to go to school.
Yes, it's about education,
because all my movies
are about love, about
education, about
intergenerational exchange
and about love too.
About love.
Well, I love you both.
And I just want to take this
opportunity to thank you for--
I'm not going to start crying--
being so loving and kind to me
at every time that I've
crossed paths with you.
When I first showed show
my film at Sundance,
in the very first screening
of Middle of Nowhere,
a woman stood up in the
audience and asked the question
in a Q&A. But it wasn't a
question, it was Julie Dash,
and she was saying
she was proud of me.
And Euzhan, you have, whenever
you come to the States,
you call me, you make sure that
we connect and break bread.
You've allowed me to share
you with other Black women
directors so that
they can meet you.
You both are huge
parts of my journey,
and I just want everyone
to know about you--
what you've done,
what you're doing,
and what you're going to do.
Together.
Together!
[GIGGLING]
Julie, you and I.
We're going to do something
together, we've been saying.
Yes, yes.
Yes, let's do that.
Thank you so much,
thank you for having us.
We love you.
Thank you for doing this.
You all are both so busy, and
so famous, and so fabulous.
It's true.
And I feel honored to have
been able to talk to you
and to have this conversation
between the two of you
that can always
be on the record.
What a thrill for
people who love film.
Love you both.
Hi, my name is a Ava
DuVernay, and for more videos,
go to the Oscars channel.